police on merseyside have tonight  arrested a 30-year-old man on suspicion  of the murder of Ellie Edwards Ellie who  was 26 was shot dead while enjoying a  drink with her sister and friends on  Christmas Eve a 28 year old man injured  in the incident remains in a critical  condition a 19 year old woman has also  been arrested on suspicion of conspiracy  to murder valence member she joins us  live now from wallacy and those updates  released by police in the last half hour  that's right Anna tonight two people are  being questioned by police after what  they called was a callous cold-blooded  murder that took place at the pub behind  me here on the Wirral on Christmas Eve a  30 year old man arrested on suspicion of  murder and attempted murder and a 19  year old woman arrested on suspicion of  conspiracy to murder this all happened  late on a day which was fueled with  emotions as those close to 26 year old  Ellie Edwards came to terms with her  death